วิธี sample-based quantum diagonalization หรือ SQD เป็นอัลกอริทึมไฮบริดควอนตัม-คลาสสิก เหมือนกับ Krylov
quantum diagonalization KQD เหมือน VQE และอีกหลายตัว เมื่อใช้
อัลกอริทึมไฮบริดพวกนี้ อาจมีประโยชน์ที่จะคิดถึงว่าแต่ละอัลกอริทึมใช้ประโยชน์จากการคำนวณควอนตัมและคลาสสิกตรงไหน จำว่า VQE สร้าง state บน quantum
circuit โดยใช้ parameter ที่ optimize จากคลาสสิก ในกรณีนั้น state เองอยู่บน quantum computer แม้
การได้ target state เป็นกระบวนการที่รวมทั้งการคำนวณคลาสสิกและควอนตัม
expectation value ของ operator คำนวณโดยใช้การวัดควอนตัม
แต่การรวม term บางส่วนแบบคลาสสิกก็จำเป็นเช่นกัน
ในทางตรงกันข้าม SQD ใช้ quantum computer เพื่อสร้าง subspace ที่มีประโยชน์ที่ Hamiltonian หรือ operator อื่นสามารถ
project ลงไปได้ จากนั้น Hamiltonian ถูก diagonalize แบบคลาสสิกทั้งหมดเพื่อหา target state สมมุติว่ามี
ปัญหาที่น่าสนใจสำหรับวิทยาศาสตร์หรืออุตสาหกรรมที่เขียนเป็นปัญหา eigen solver บนเมทริกซ์ n แถวและ
n คอลัมน์ได้ สมมุติต่อว่า n ใหญ่พอที่ exact classical diagonalization ไม่ใช่ตัวเลือก มัน
ชัดเจนว่าจะเป็นประโยชน์ถ้าลดมิติของเมทริกซ์ได้โดยยังรักษาคุณสมบัติที่เกี่ยวข้องทั้งหมดของ ground state ไว้ นั่นคือ
เป้าหมายของแนวทาง eigen solver แบบประมาณหลายอย่าง รวมถึง classical Krylov methods สมมุติว่าเรารู้พอเกี่ยวกับปัญหา
เพื่อเดา form ของ ground state ได้ค่อนข้างดี แต่ไม่พอที่จะแก้ปัญหาได้ทันที ในกรณี
นั้น เราสามารถวัดการประมาณที่ค่อนข้างดีของ target ground state ได้หลายครั้ง ผลลัพธ์ของ
การวัดเหล่านั้นให้ subspace ของ computational basis state ที่มี component ที่เกี่ยวข้องทั้งหมดของ
ground state ของเรา การ project ลงบน subspace นั้นจะให้เมทริกซ์ที่เล็กกว่าที่ยังมี degree of freedom
ที่เกี่ยวข้อง workflow สำหรับสิ่งนี้เป็นดังนี้ คุณเริ่มด้วยการเลือก
ansatz ที่ดี โดยเฉพาะเลือก ansatz ที่มี support ตรงกับ target state เราจะพูดถึงว่ามันหมายความว่าอะไรกันแน่
ต่อไป วัด state ใน computational basis ตามที่ทำกับ sampler primitive
จากนั้น ใช้ผลลัพธ์ของการ sampling เพื่อกำหนด subspace ที่มี ground state
แล้ว project เมทริกซ์ของคุณลงบน subspace นั้น สุดท้าย diagonalize เมทริกซ์ที่ project แล้วขนาดเล็กกว่าแบบคลาสสิก
มาแยกแยะแต่ละขั้นตอนเหล่านี้ โดยให้ความสนใจพิเศษกับการกำหนด subspace
ตลอดการคำนวณควอนตัมทั้งหมด การเลือก ansatz ที่ดีสำคัญเสมอ ในกรณีของ SQD การเลือก ansatz ของคุณ
จะกำหนดว่า computational basis state ใดอาจถูกวัดในการ sampling
true ground state สามารถแสดงเป็น superposition ของ computational basis state บาง subset ได้ subset นั้น
เรียกว่า support ของ ground state เพื่อให้ได้การประมาณที่ดีของ ground state และพลังงาน ansatz ของคุณ
ต้องมี projection ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์ลงบน computational basis state ใน support ของ ground state
ไดอะแกรมนี้แสดง space ที่ครอบคลุมโดย state ทั้งหมดที่เป็นไปได้บนจำนวน qubit ที่ใช้ เราต้องการ
ansatz ที่มี support ที่มี support ของ true ground state อยู่ด้วย
ลองพิจารณาตัวอย่างเล็กมากๆ ที่มี ground state เป็น s ground คือ 8 คูณ
state 1 0 0 บวก 6 คูณ state 001
มันมี support ทำจากเวกเตอร์สองตัว 1 0 0 และ 0 0 1 สมมุติว่า ansatz มีรูปแบบ ansatz 1 คือ A คูณ
state 1 0 0 บวก B คูณ state 0 1 0 บวก C คูณ state 001 ดังนั้น
support ของมันคือชุดเวกเตอร์สามตัว 1 0 0, 0 1 0 และ 0 0 1 ซึ่งเป็น superset ของ
support ของ ground state นี่คือ ansatz ที่ดี
ตอนนี้จินตนาการว่าเลือก ansatz ที่มีรูปแบบ ansatz 2 คือ a คูณ
state 1 1 0 บวก b คูณ state 011
มันมี support ทำจากเวกเตอร์สองตัว 1 1 0 และ 0 1 1 ซึ่งไม่มีความทับซ้อนกับ support ของ ground
state เลย นี่คือ ansatz ที่แย่
โปรดทราบว่าเราไม่จำเป็นต้องให้ ansatz เป็นการประมาณ ground state ที่ดี ansatz อาจมี
support ที่ใหญ่กว่ามาก หรือ coefficient อาจต่างกันมากบน ansatz และ true ground state และยังทำงานได้ดี
ณ ขั้นนี้ เราใช้ ansatz ที่มีเหตุผลดีให้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมรับ state ที่คล้ายกับ target
state ของเรา แสดงที่นี่คือ unitary coupled cluster หรือ UCJ ansatz ซึ่งมีประโยชน์มากใน quantum chemistry
ตอนนี้เราต้องการวัด state ของระบบ ได้ bitstring ที่อธิบาย collapsed state ของแต่ละ
qubit จำว่าการประมาณ Hamiltonian เช่นใน VQE ต้องการการวัดควอนตัมมากมาย ส่วนหนึ่งเพื่อ
ลดความไม่แน่นอน และส่วนหนึ่งเนื่องจากจำนวนกลุ่มของ Pauli ที่ commute ที่ประกอบเป็น Hamiltonian
ใน sampling methods คุณยังต้องการการวัดมาก แต่เหตุผลต่างกัน ตอนนี้เราต้องการการวัดมากเพื่อ sample
computational basis state จำนวนมากที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ quantum state ที่ entangle กันสูง ใน SQD bitstring ที่ sample ได้สอดคล้อง
กับ configuration ของระบบที่จำลอง ถ้าระบบที่ศึกษาอยู่ภายใต้ข้อจำกัดแน่นอนอย่าง
conservation law ในฟิสิกส์หรือเคมี ส่วนใหญ่ของ state ที่วัดได้จะถูกต้อง แต่บาง bitstring ที่ sample
สอดคล้องกับ configuration ที่ไม่ถูกต้องหรือไม่ใช่ physical เนื่องจาก noise และ error กระบวนการที่เรียกว่า
configuration recovery มีเป้าหมายปรับปรุง noisy sample เหล่านี้ให้เป็น configuration ที่แม่นยำกว่า
กระบวนการนี้เกี่ยวข้องกับการสร้าง configuration ใหม่โดย flip bit แต่ละตัวแบบ probabilistic ตาม
occupancy ของ orbital โดยเฉลี่ยและจำนวนอนุภาคที่รู้
configuration ที่ปรับปรุงแล้วจะถูกใช้เพื่อครอบคลุม subspace สำหรับ Hamiltonian projection และ diagonalization
โดย iteratively ปรับปรุง fidelity ของการแสดง quantum state
มาดูตัวอย่างเล็กๆ ที่เข้าใจง่ายของ configuration recovery เพื่อทำความเข้าใจความหมาย สมมุติว่าวัด
ระบบควอนตัมที่มี qubit สี่ตัวแทน molecular orbital สี่ตัวและได้ bitstring ต่อไปนี้จาก
quantum processor แต่ละ bitstring แสดง occupancy ของ orbital หนึ่งสำหรับ
อยู่, ศูนย์สำหรับว่าง Qiskit ใช้สัญลักษณ์ที่ least significant qubit อยู่ทางขวาสุด
ตัวอย่างเช่น 1 0 1 0 บ่งบอกว่า orbital 1 และ 3 ถูก occupy อยู่ การวัด
เหล่านี้เลือกมาด้วยเหตุผลทางการศึกษาเท่านั้น occupancy ที่ได้อาจไม่ตรงกับระบบ physical ในบริบท physical มักเป็น
กรณีที่ระบบมีจำนวนอนุภาครวมที่รู้จัก อาจมี conservation law อื่นๆ ที่
คุณใช้เพื่อพิจารณา physicality ของ state ที่วัดได้ เพื่อให้เป็นรูปธรรม สมมุติว่าระบบของเรา
ทราบกันว่ามีจำนวนอนุภาครวม n เท่ากับ 2 นี่บอกเราว่าจำนวนหนึ่งรวมที่ควรปรากฏใน state
label ของเรา ซึ่งเรียกว่า Hamming weight constraint
อย่างไรก็ตาม configuration บางอย่างที่วัดได้ละเมิด constraint นี้ state 1 0 1 0 ถูกต้องใน physical แต่ state 1 1
1 0 มีอนุภาคมากเกินไปและ state ที่เป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมดมีอนุภาคน้อยเกินไป ศูนย์
ตัว ความละเมิดเหล่านี้อาจเกิดจาก noise ในระบบหรือ error ในการวัด เราต้องการวิธีกลับสู่
configuration ที่มีความหมาย physical อย่างน้อยในแบบประมาณ
นี่เรียกว่า configuration recovery
เพื่อแก้ไข noisy sample เรา flip bit ใน configuration ที่ไม่ถูกต้องแบบ probabilistic ตาม
occupancy ของ orbital โดยเฉลี่ยจาก configuration ที่ถูกต้อง
occupancy ของ orbital คือ expectation value ของ number operator ที่ทำงานกับแต่ละ orbital ค่านี้ประมาณและ
ปรับปรุงแบบ self-consistently โดยใช้ state ที่ได้จาก SQD มาดู orbital 2 เป็นตัวอย่าง ในสองของ
สี่ configuration ที่ถูกต้อง orbital 2 ถูก occupy ทำให้ค่า expected occupancy คือ 0.5
เราทำเช่นเดียวกันกับ orbital อีกสามตัว ตอนนี้กลับมาที่ configuration ที่ไม่ถูกต้อง 1 1 0 เรา flip หนึ่งใน
bit จาก 1 เป็น 0 เพื่อสร้าง configuration ที่ถูกต้อง แต่ควร flip อันไหน วิธีหนึ่งในการตัดสินใจคือ
ผ่านความเบี่ยงเบนของ occupancy ของแต่ละ orbital จากค่าเฉลี่ยที่คำนวณไว้
ตรงนี้เราเห็นว่าความแตกต่างที่ใหญ่ที่สุดอยู่ใน occupation ของ orbital 1 ดังนั้นเราคาดว่า bit 1 ควร
ถูก flip จาก 1 เป็น 0 แน่นอน orbital 2 ก็ไม่ห่างกันมาก และมีความเป็นไปได้เสมอ แม้จะไม่น่าจะเป็น ว่า
state ที่วัดนั้นเป็นผลจาก error หลายตัวบน state เดียวกัน
การเลือกแค่ความเบี่ยงเบนจากค่าเฉลี่ยที่ใหญ่ที่สุดสำหรับ state ที่ไม่ถูกต้องทั้งหมดไม่ใช่วิธีที่ optimal แต่ bit จะถูก flip
แบบ probabilistic โดยมีความน่าจะเป็นเป็นฟังก์ชันของความแตกต่างที่แสดงที่นี่ สมมุติว่าใน
กรณีนี้เราเปลี่ยน bit ที่ต่างจากค่า occupation เฉลี่ยมากที่สุด ดังนั้น 1 1 0 จะกลายเป็น 1 0 0 เราจะทำ
กระบวนการเดิมสำหรับตัวเลือกที่ไม่ถูกต้องอีกตัว สมมุติว่าในกรณีนี้เราลง end up ด้วยการ flip bit 1 และ 3
หลังจากกระบวนการแก้ไขนี้ เรามีชุด configuration ใหม่ที่อาจมีลักษณะแบบนี้
โดยใช้ชุดที่ปรับปรุงแล้วนี้ เราสามารถอัปเดต occupancy ของ orbital โดยเฉลี่ยเพื่อปรับปรุง fidelity ในกรณีของเรา
occupancy ใหม่คือสิ่งเหล่านี้
กระบวนการ iterative recovery นี้ช่วยให้การวัดที่ noisy ถูกกรองให้เป็น configuration ที่มีความหมาย physical
ปรับปรุงความแม่นยำของการประมาณ eigen state ใน SQD SQD Qiskit add-on มีเครื่องมือบางอย่างที่
จะมีประโยชน์ในกระบวนการนี้ ถ้าเราทำงานดี sampling state ใน support ของ true ground state
ของระบบ เราควรสามารถดูแค่ส่วนของ Hamiltonian ที่ทำงานกับ subspace นี้
และยังได้ ground state และพลังงานที่ดี ในตัวอย่าง 4 qubit เล็กมากๆ ของเรา มีตอนแรก 2 ยกกำลัง 4 หรือ 16
state ที่เป็นไปได้ของระบบ โดยใช้การรวม sampling และ configuration recovery เราลดสิ่งนี้
เป็นสาม state ใน subspace ที่สนใจ สาม state ที่เราหวังว่าจะเป็น support ของ true ground state
เราตอนนี้ project full Hamiltonian ลงบน subspace นั้น นั่นคือเราสร้างเมทริกซ์ M จากคอลัมน์ของเวกเตอร์จาก
recovered sampled subspace และ M dagger ที่คล้ายกันจากแถว และเราคูณ M dagger HM
ในเชิงภาพ หมายความว่านำ matrix element ในแถวและคอลัมน์ที่สอดคล้องกับ state ใน
recovered sampled subspace ของเรา แถวและคอลัมน์ที่ highlight คือแถวที่สอดคล้องกับ subspace ของเรา และ
กล่องที่ highlight เข้มกว่าที่ตัดกันคือ element ที่เราเก็บไว้สำหรับ projected matrix ใหม่
ตอนนี้ที่เราเลือก subspace ที่สนใจออกมาแล้ว เราสามารถ diagonalize เมทริกซ์นี้บนคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
โดยใช้ standard solver ถ้า true ground state ประกอบด้วย state ใน subspace ของเราทั้งหมด
การ diagonalize ควรให้ ground state ที่ถูกต้องและ ground state energy ถ้าเรามีแค่ส่วนใหญ่ของ ground state
support เราอาจได้ใกล้เคียง เมื่อได้ ground state สำหรับ projected Hamiltonian นี้แล้ว เรามี
state ที่มีประโยชน์มากในการคำนวณ occupancy เฉลี่ยของแต่ละ orbital
ก่อนหน้านี้ occupancy ของเราคำนวณจาก state ที่ sample โดยใช้ ansatz ที่เราหวังว่าจะช่วย
เข้าใกล้ ground state แต่ไม่มีการรับประกันว่า occupancy เฉลี่ยของแต่ละ orbital จากการ sampling นั้นสอดคล้องกับ occupancy
ใน lowest energy state มาย้อนกลับไป เรามีการ sampling ของ computational state เราใช้ configuration recovery
เพื่อแก้ไขที่ไม่ถูกต้องใน physical จากนั้นคำนวณ occupancy ของ orbital โดยเฉลี่ยโดยใช้ทั้งหมด
ground state อาจมีแค่บางส่วนเท่านั้น ground state ของ projected Hamiltonian นี้อาจไม่ใช่ true ground
state ของระบบเดิม แต่มันคือ lowest energy state ที่สร้างได้โดยใช้ superposition ใดก็ได้ของ
recovered state ใน subspace ของเรา occupancy ของ orbital ของ state นี้จะให้พลังงานน้อยกว่าหรือเท่ากับ
พลังงานของ occupancy ที่ได้จาก recovered space ดังนั้น occupancy นี้เป็นการประมาณที่ดีกว่าของ
ground state occupancy ของเรา เราสามารถทำกระบวนการ configuration recovery ซ้ำโดยใช้ occupancy ใหม่นี้ และ iterate
จนกว่าเงื่อนไข convergence ของเราจะตอบสนอง sample-based quantum diagonalization รวดเร็วเมื่อเทียบกับ
อัลกอริทึม near-term อื่นๆ อย่าง VQE มัน scalable กว่าและมีความทนทานต่อ noise และ error ในการ sampling มัน
ยังต้องการให้เราเตรียม ansatz ที่ดีที่มี projection ขนาดใหญ่ภายใต้ support ของ true ground state ของระบบ ถ้าไม่รู้อะไรเลย
เกี่ยวกับ true ground state ของเรา SQD อาจต้องใช้ร่วมกับวิธีอื่นๆ เพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับ
ground state ก่อนและ iterate เข้าหามันทีละขั้น
SQD มีบทบาทสำคัญในชุด classical quantum hybrid algorithm ที่กำลังเกิดขึ้น และเป็นหนึ่งใน
ปัจจัยสำคัญที่สุดในการขับเคลื่อนไปสู่ quantum computing ที่มีประโยชน์